once again i haven't said this in a
while thank you for clicking on my face
i do appreciate it before we talk about
jordan peele's third i want to give some
love to the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by display
display offers high quality prints on
metal with a myriad of options available
video games comic books comic book
movies i love night trap and i bring up
those examples because they're
entertainment that's kind of what i talk
about here but they don't just have
entertainment they have some other
amazing prints of life nature astronomy
and hanging them really simple just wipe
down the wall hang the magnet magnet
sticks to the wall the print sticks to
the magnet as simple as that if and when
you want to change it out maybe it's
halloween tis the season as easy as
changing out a magnet on the fridge so
click the link below and get 25 off of
one or two prints or 29 off of three or
more prints that is for a limited time
so best not to wait too long and now
nope
[Music]
also yeah you saw that wall correctly
vhs ain't dead while i'm breathing also
this is a spoiler free review no
spoilers in here so nope is jordan
peel's third film it stars daniel
kaluuya and kiki palmer they play
brother and sister they own this horse
ranch then they see something in the sky
and they want to catch it on video and
from there it just escalates to
what's been aptly described as spectacle
and funny enough i feel like i'm this
this movie's two films but first the
cast i thought the cast in this movie
was great daniel kaluuya kiki palmer
kiki palmer's the standout she's
energetic she's charismatic daniel
kahlua is the more reserved stoic type
kiki palmer undeniably has an energy to
her that is just engaging she's also the
one the humor in this movie comes from
this movie's funnier than get out and us
which in 2022 you're like oh yeah humor
in the movie i know it's one of those
things where you knuckle up you're like
what kind not the kind of humor that
compromises any of the tension i didn't
feel the humor and the tension were at
war with each other at all it just felt
natural to get props for that but also
they're not the only two there are a
couple support characters i didn't see
in the trailers at all i feel like the
newer trailers at a point i was like
trailer shows too much i don't want to
see maybe it showed them in there and i
missed them also if you feel like that
trailer showed too much it really didn't
there's still a lot you don't know about
the movie just letting you know it's
when the four of them are working
together that dynamic is when this movie
is at its height also movie's not a
horror movie i know i've seen people say
oh horror movie it's a horror movie it's
not a horror movie i'm just letting you
know i feel like that's really what i do
here is i tell you my opinion about a
movie but really the deeper quest of the
channels when something's misbranded i
can let you know so you actually know
what you're in for the movie's not a
horror thriller yes i would call it a
thriller some great scenes of tension in
here horror
which is a bummer because at cinemacon
jordan peel came out and he was talking
about the movies he makes he makes to
recapture that feeling that he would get
and that reaction the audience would
give when he would watch horror movies
he was talking about how people would
scream at the screen nope get out things
like that actually there is one scene
that did get that reaction from the
audience i saw it in a pretty packed
auditorium there was one scene where
people start screaming the jordan peel
movie titles at the screen they're like
nope get out it was intense and it's the
scene that actually made the hair in the
back of my neck stand up it was actually
kind of incredible i loved the feeling i
loved the audience reaction it was a
great time and then that scene ends
and it's kind of irrelevant and it never
happens again not sure if jordan peel's
trying to defy expectations or just
trolling because obviously he knows what
the audience wants he's like yeah i know
you want that but i'm gonna give you
something else and when i talk about
this movie felt like two movies that's a
nice way of saying the first half of
this movie i found to be boring second
half is actually pretty enthralling now
when a movie does that i try to see that
first hour that first half as character
development but an hour into the movie
you know exactly what you knew from the
second scene in the movie kiki palmer
being energetic engaging daniel kahlua
being stoic a couple of character
moments or things otherwise shine
through yeah sure in terms of how it
plays out if you say oh hey half the
movie i found boring the other half of
the movie i found good that only really
works if the first half is the boring
half if a movie starts out with the
first hour being great and then the
second hour isn't it feels like a nose
dive but if a movie's slow at first and
then builds to something it's a climb
and the audience leaves the movie
theater with that feeling and that's
absolutely what happens with this you
give the first hour of this movie a pass
because the second hour of the movie
picks up and it's actually pretty cool i
will say there was also this side arc
backstory with this chimp that i don't
feel really connected with the film
itself which is funny i can see how it
ties in with one of the themes of the
movie but i think that theme would land
just as well as it did in the movie
without the chimp backstory side arc so
it's easy for me to look at that and be
like oh that's where you could have
shaved some time that would have saved
but being honest this movie does remind
me of another movie i mean most movies
are like oh it's like a mix between that
movie and that movie but this is a very
famous movie just wearing a ufo mask i
get that there's a fine line between
homage and ripoff you can decide
wherever that line is for yourself in
the end nope is one of those movies
we've all been there with a movie
experience like this where you watch
movies the movie ends off in a way where
the last act is actually exciting and it
leaves you with that feeling of yeah
that was fun and then on your drive home
maybe to drive home maybe you get home
and you get yourself a snack point is
you start thinking about it more and the
negative starts stacking and in a world
where the internet seems to be love it
all or hate it all this is one of those
movies that is in line with the other 99
of other things in the world it's in the
middle and it's fine i enjoyed it just
fine it's a fun spin on the ufo on the
farm plot and i'll say it's worth a
watch no alcohol required at matinee
price there you go i feel like matinee
used to be cheaper what is it 15 bucks
for matinee now all right so nope are
you looking forward to it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you